n
principe les urgences, ou les
infirmières pourront vous
recevoir, comme nous explique
Davide Gentile.
- Depuis des semaines,
les urgences débordent.
Mercredi, le taux d'occupation
des civières était de 132 %.
Une des solutions, c'est
la création de cliniquesd'd'd'is
spécialisées.
Mercredi, on s'affaire
aux derniers préparatif
avant l'ouverture prévue
ici jeudi après-midi.
- À partir de jeudi
1er décembre, c'est ça,
vous allez pouvoir... nous voir,
les infirmières praticiennes.
- Nadine Belony est
l'une des trois infirmières
qui vont lancer les activités.
Elle le fera en plus
de sa tâche régulière
dans une autre clinique.
NADINE BELONY, IPS, CIUSSS
de l'Est-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
- D'offrir du temps
supplémentaire volontaire pour
pouvoir commencer la clinique.
- Elle fera du temps
supplémentaire ici pour soulager
ses collègues dans les urgences.
C'est d'ailleurs le principal
objectif de cette nouvelle
clinique.
LINA SPAGNUOLO, dir. CIUSSS
de l'Est-de-l'Île-de-Montréal
- Tester un modèle et surtout
d'enlever de la pression sur
nos équipes dans nos salles
d'urgence. Vous voyeatatatat
de nos salles d'urgence,
surtout dans l'est, au niveau de
l'Hôpital Maisonneuve-Rosemont,
l'Hôpital Santa Cabrini
Ospedale, alors c'est sûr que
tout ce qu'on va pouvoir offrir
va enlever de la pression.
- Des patients des urgences
de l'est de Montréal
pourraient êtres référé ici.
Ces infirmières praticiennes
spécialisées peuvent
diagnostiquer plusieurs
maladies et même prescrire
des médicaments.
- Un enfant qui a un rhume,
donc... puis on voit beaucoup
aussi de patients...
de patients qui se présentent
pour des infections urinaires.
- Presque tout le matériel
médical était dé p p p p place.
C'est que les infirmières
remplacent des médecins
qui sont para a a a a retraite.
- C'est un CLSC qui a connu
une baisse d'activité
dans ls s s s s passées,
alors c'est sûr que
c'est une façon pour nous
de redonner de la vie à ce CLSC.
ararararart, on verra ici
250 patients par semaine.
Deux autres cliniques d'IPS
ouvriront à Montréal
d'ici février.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.